Michael Carone down low against Sanderson ends
up in behind the EMP for Jack McBain kessle ring
to the middle McBain with a shot had save there
Corpus Sal now steter to the front little a drop
there schz and he couldn't set it up and it's
raced back by tereno he's got jaru with him
and a shot over the top and wide by teraso and It
Go was over the glass and out that's another guy
who forgot to mention one of the best Shooters
in the game today quick snapper good job there
by valam you go back to his numbers last year 50
points between the blues and the Rangers he was
was kind of the the one player the early trade
that kind of kicked off of the deadline with
a bunch of big deals right in behind and it
now back out high for Zu and his shot a score
off of the flexion and the Ottawa Senators have
taken a one- nothing lead I believe that's Angus
Kook shank yeah you bet you again face offs how
important are they the otwa Senators pick it up
around the horn they go and we just going to get
this Puck a Rolling Puck and he throws it right
at the net this was going to be a good 5 ft wide
but you get it there and good things happen look
at the redirection there those goes off the Stick
of kir shank and off the Ci's defenseman in front
I believe that was all he's will look to counter
at Center ice and Logan kie has it moved along
in over the line here's a chance in front Dumba
can't get a pass and a rebound there for zooker
is covered getting involved zooker follows up the
Dumba shot real nice move there by Dumba as well
tries to go back against the grain on the forehand
andala with a big left toe save and zooker now
melli stab they'll get it in suer on the setup out
High Alami and AC cross aell one timer zooker in a
stop cor pasalo and look at that pass by melli
he's looking at the golender like turn to see
how Keith was absorbing the moment with Brady and
we caught it as well absolutely love that what a
what a moment is up for a dad and a goal put home
Josh Norris power play tally two- nothing Ottawa
one of the coyot top penalty killers in the box
and real good Puck movement and what a shot I
mean that is an absolute bullet of a shot by
Norris gets all of that one and not sure if
Conor Ingram was screened on this one or not
but that is absolutely ripped JJ Moser is kind
of right in the vicinity Mattias melli try to
move it around here at Dumba L and cruss as
well give it away chance in
front they score again on a
redirect kubiks made it 3 nothing gerit can't
handle the Pucket and that's a that's a tough
save to make and this is probably just more
about changing the momentum of this hockey
game as that puck the slids and you know
he's looking to impress the coaching staff
as well every night every day you're you're
evaluated especially when your numbers are
those durman to the middle and just set wide
on the redirect by Krauss puck gets back to
durit watch the redirection in front by K on
the forehand just a little Chip Shot Alami
and stetcher that pairing remains intact
for head coach Andre turny and it will be
brought along Keller brings it in Keller AC
cross schs right to the front they bat away
at it they can't get it home in Cur foot
that's time and space far left your screen
gets that pocket what a beautiful feed couple of
players go flying cot on the ice along with Kook
shank from the line Berard Docker with
a shot and a follow up kachuck not too
long ago chicken put up 18 goals I that
defenseman and flipped out High kul's
going to go get it played across for Keller
Coy's get it set up again schaltz beads it
out High Moser Moser with a wrist shot stop
rebound Kook can't buy it 4 seconds to go
so the coyotes are going to come up empty
on this power play as it's brought in by
kie kie tried to get it to the front
herone behind the net spit a shot
right to the grease they score Jack mcpain
even strength goal and the lead is cut to
two but look at the coyotes they work down
low Kon Logan kly involved as well and J's
going to pick this one up he throws it right
at the net Jack mcpain right place right time
another stop by Cor it goes right to the Stick of
McBain who buries it that is such a big goal for
the big man and now zooker eight to go comes
in front kie might get a look derit oh what
a stop coroso nice play there by coie to find
derit and he almost finds the back of the net
cor pasalo has certainly been a story here
tonight to car's out shooting the auto off
senators put it out by
Dum Sanderson back Center ice it go stla
get over the line to the front he can't
finish it off pson was there trickers sends
it around machell big hit there machell gets
it right back skates in rebound they score JJ
Moser on a followup and it's a one goal game
pucks and people to the net melli takes
it to the middle of the ice and JJ Moser
sneaks down the left side not sure if
that went off a corpus Salo or not but
right onto the twig of JJ Moser and
he buries it into a wide empty cage
Corpus Salo almost gets over to deny
Moser look at this effort by Cor pasalo
they just do not go away down three nothing
to unanswered Keller brings it in try to drop
it for stetcher stetcher got it down to the
corner they St they tied it and it's Clayton
Keller what an answer ride that wave Clayton
Keller turns fires Spin arama and he catches
Corp pasalo I'm not sure how that went in
help is on the way in form of Troy stetcher
schz will try to bring it up PES will get it
out and here they come kerfoot Alex kerfoot
drops it stetcher shoots and a glove save
Corpus Salo durit shoots stop that time got
through carcone shoots and another save
Corpus Salo in front chance kessle ring
shoots another save and it goes in it goes in
Kastle Ring's going to get credited from the
goal the pressure McBain how about that
little spitama the Coy's all over the
Senators they got five guys back but they
can't stop they can't contain this group
the Cs just kept firing and that goes off
of hamic and into the back of the net shot
towards the front denied by schaltz schaltz
looks up ice Keller towards the empty nety at
the post oh my stla behind the net taken
away by stetcher tried to send it around
right to the front it's underneath and that's
going to do it coyotes win it what a comeback